[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit kaiser
berichte und christian sievers
guten abend in allen an einem tag an dem
wieder regen kommt auch in die
katastrophengebiete in rheinland pfalz
und nordrhein westfalen
es ist nicht vergleichbar mit den
furchtbaren regenfällen vor eineinhalb
wochen aber vorsichtshalber hat der
lokale krisenstab den betroffenen
menschen evakuierungen angeboten jetzt
bloß keine weiteren risiken eingehen das
ist die lage im moment in deutschland
lila das sind gewitter sie ziehen jetzt
richtung norden ab die kräftigsten
unwetter kommen in dieser nacht aus den
alpen heraus und betreffen baden
württemberg und bayern
und das ist die belgische provinz namur
heute abend sind wieder bilder die
schlimmes ahnen lassen
auch belgien hatte viele todesopfer zu
beklagen und in den unwetter
geschädigten regionen im westen
deutschlands führt schon ein bisschen
regen zu neuen problemen wie dominik
löschmeister zeigt die bundeswehr bahnt
in schuld im aartal vor neuen
regenfällen
der deutsche wetterdienst geht zwar
nicht von einer neuen
unwetterkatastrophe aus rechnet aber mit
örtlichen niederschlägen von 30 bis 40
litern pro quadratmeter
deshalb haben wir uns auch entsprechend
vorbereitet und den besonders
betroffenen kommunen ein evakuierungs
angebot unterbreitet mit shuttle bussen
aus den gefährdeten regionen auch
evakuiert zu werden schon kleinere
gewitter ein problem in den
hochwassergebieten das wasser kann
vielerorts schlecht abfließen
hinzu kommt treibgut es könnte
mitgerissen werden oder zum neuen
überschwemmungen führen vorhersagen sind
schwierig häufig entwickeln sich
gewitter so schnell dass wir erst eine
halbe stunde vorher sagen können wo sie
denn sich bildet und manchmal haben so
gewitterzellen auch die angewohnheit
einfach anders zu ziehen als es
ursprünglich aussah und schlagen so ein
haken das macht die gewitter prognose
wirklich sehr sehr kompliziert und
schwierig die hilfsbereitschaft sie wird
überall gelobt hunderte machten sich am
wochenende auf den weg in den landkreis
ahrweiler was dazu führte dass zufall
kassen völlig überlastet waren deswegen
möchten wir gerade jetzt unbedingt durch
die witterung alle spontan helfer
auffordern heute im laufe des
nachmittags das gebiet zunächst zu
verlassen
nur nicht so viel regen dass hoffen sie
in den hochwassergebieten im westen 1530
hat der goldschmied wilhelm prüm einen
familienbetrieb zur herstellung von
messing und kupfer gegründet das
unternehmen in stolberg bei aachen gibt
es immer noch es gilt als
weltmarktführer für druckknöpfe wenn man
seit 1530 existiert dann kann ein wenig
umbauen sollte man meinen
das hochwasser hat es dennoch geschafft
ralph goldmann jetzt über ein beispiel
wie die katastrophe auch die wirtschaft
aus dem takt bringt es ist ein beispiel
von vielen
iss aufgebrochen firmenchef axel wirth
müller zeigt uns das ganze ausmaß der
katastrophe im keller des unternehmens
stapeln sich dutzende schwere metall
spende
es sind nicht die eigenen es sind die
des nachbar unternehmens aurubis die
kraft des wassers hat sie herein gespürt
es stand am ende zwei meter hoch der
kleine sichtbar war außer kontrolle
geraten die feuerwehr nutzte die
belegschaft aus der firma
wenn man diese ohnmacht sie dass man
nichts tun kann dass man mit der
feuerwehr mit vereinten kräften versucht
hat etwas zu retten und man dann sieht
es hat keinen sinn mehr
das ist das ist schwer das ist schwer
also es waren einige mitarbeiter dabei
die richtig gemeint haben die die gesagt
haben wir haben gekämpft aber verloren
darum gilt als das älteste industrielle
familienunternehmen deutschland sie
produzieren unter anderem druckknöpfe
für die bekleidungsindustrie axel wirth
müller hat eine solche flut in 40 jahren
noch nicht erlebt
das ist unser materiallager was also
komplett geflutet war alle materialien
die wir hier bei uns auf lager haben
eine produktion ist derzeit nicht zu
denken
der wirtschaftliche schaden ist riesig
das ist mit sicherheit eine mehrstellige
millionensumme da kann man vom ausgehen
und ich sag mal da eine verlässliche
aussage zu treffen ist einfach noch zu
früh aber es ist ein hartes stück arbeit
was da vor uns leben tausende
unternehmen in nrw sind von der flut
betroffen nicht nur industriebetriebe in
der stollberger fußgängerzone haben die
fluten des richters praktisch alle
geschäfte und restaurants zerstört sie
müssen wieder komplett neu aufgebaut
werden
basisinfrastruktur war zunächst mal weg
strom gas wasser auch telekommunikation
dazustehen ladenlokale unterwasser lager
sind aufgelöst material ist verwüstet
also insoweit ist ein regelbetrieb bei
vielen unternehmen auch bei
industriebetrieben zurzeit nicht möglich
und viele arbeitsplätze könnten verloren
gehen beibringen müssen 170 von etwas
kühler mit beschäftigten in kurzarbeit
der chef gibt sich kämpferisch auf jeden
fall ist der wille nicht nur von der
geschäftsführung auch von der familie da
ganz klar hier mitarbeiter zu machen
hier wieder aufzubauen und das versuchen
wir jetzt mit vereinten kräften und die
kunden werden viel geduld brauchen bis
gründen wieder ware liefern kann
wann die produktion hier aber wieder
anläuft das ist noch völlig offen
und jetzt in der sendung bilder aus
budapest heute auch das ist ungewohnt
weltoffene liberale es ist nicht dass
ungarn von regierungschef viktor orban
dessen politik sich verstärkt gegen
homosexuelle und andere sexuelle
minderheiten richtet ein gesetz das die
darstellung von homosexualität verbietet
in medien zu denen kinder zugang haben
gibt es schon
das dürfte das zentrale thema für seine
wahlkampagne werden im kommenden jahr
jetzt plant er noch eine volksabstimmung
dazu in budapest haben tausende heute
auf ihre art abgestimmt es war die wohl
größte pride parade die es dort bislang
gab
und die wohl mutigste wolf christian
ullrich sie wurde nicht unsichtbar
gemacht werden zehntausende bei der
pride demonstration in budapest heute so
viele wie noch nie
sie protestieren gegen ein neues gesetz
der orban regierung nachdem in ungarn
jugendliche nichts mehr über homo und
transsexualität erfahren dürfen
[Musik]
jetzt bei sigrid wir wollen uns aus der
öffentlichkeit streichen
aus den medien und aus den schulen was
das gesetz konkret bedeutet zeigt sich
bei diesem buch lagen hier sieht man
sich jetzt dazu gezwungen solche
schilder anzubringen
hier werden nicht traditionelle inhalte
verkauft gemeint sind eher mit
kinderbücher wie dieses in dem eine
familie mit zwei vätern zu sehen lässt
wir wissen nicht was andeutung von
homosexualität bedeuten soll beklagt der
buchhändler
da muss man den schülern auf shakespeare
rambo und thomas mann verbieten
thomas mann auch mitglieder des
europäischen parlaments sind nach
budapest gekommen
die eu sieht die achtung der gleichheit
und der menschenwürde im eben vertrag
verletzt und hat deshalb ein
vertragsverletzungsverfahren gegen
ungarn auf den weg gebracht für mich
wirkt das wie eine demokratie die unter
akutem sauerstoffmangel leitet wir sehen
hier ein autoritäres regime dass
minderheiten angreift um an der macht zu
bleiben
ungarns ministerpräsident orban hat
jetzt ein referendum über das gesetz
angekündigt er sammelt schon munition
für den kommenden wahlkampf zu seinen
lieblings feinden gehört dabei auch die
eu aktuell stänkert er mit einer
plakatkampagne gegen die europäischen
partner
und das obwohl ungarn der zweitgrößte
empfänger von eu geld ist
brüssel hat in den vergangenen wochen
ungarn angegriffen wegen unseres
kinderschutzgesetzes
die eu nennt es einen diskriminierungs
gesetze in jedem fall aber soll der
konflikt ablenken von einem
ungeheuerlichen vorwurf der orban vor
wenigen tagen in die internationalen
schlagzeilen brachte unliebsame
journalisten anwälte und
oppositionspolitiker von ungarischen
behörden abgehört mit hilfe von pegasus
einer software die dafür gedacht ist
handys von kriminellen und terroristen
auszuspionieren
die pegasus affäre dazu noch große
korruptionsskandale die regierung
benutzt uns um die aufmerksamkeit von
ihren politischen skandal abzulenken
seit jahren macht die regierung orban
auf dem rücken von minderheiten
wahlkampf die wut darüber ist hier heute
groß denn demokratie sagen sie heißt
schließlich auch minderheiten zu
schützen und die nachrichtenübersicht an
diesem samstagabend hat jetzt keine
server die hochwasserlage in deutschland
war auch thema beim treffen der g20
umweltminister in neapel solche
naturkatastrophen veränderten das
bewusstsein sagte gastgeber cingular nie
zum abschluss dennoch konnte man sich
nicht auf ehrgeizigere ziele einigen als
im walliser klimaschutz abkommen
vereinbart und konkrete schritte wurden
auch nicht beschlossen
die korona zahlen steigen weiter deshalb
steigt der druck auf die impfverweigerer
ihnen sollte man nicht die gleichen
freiheiten zurückgeben wie geimpften
fordert saarlands ministerpräsident hans
es könne nicht sein dass sich für
geimpfte nichts ändert nur weil die
gesellschaft dauerhaft rücksicht auf die
verweigerer nehmen müsse sagte er dem
redaktions netzwerk deutschland in
frankreich haben mehr als 160 tausend
menschen gegen die korona politik der
regierung demonstriert konkret wehren
sie sich gegen die geplante impfpflicht
für gesundheitspersonal und
rettungskräfte in paris gab es
zusammenstöße mit der polizei
viele protestieren auch gegen einen
gesundheitspass mit dem geimpfte
genesene und getestete ihren status
nachweisen können und in vielen
einrichtungen auch müssen besondere ehre
für drei deutsche kurorte baden-baden
bad ems und bad kissingen tragen künftig
den titel welterbe
außerdem hat das unesco komitee die
darmstädter mathildenhöhe ausgezeichnet
die künstlerkolonie war eines der
wichtigsten zentren moderner architektur
nicht einfach ein jungs den ensemble
sondern ein schritt zum bauhaus
am darm auf deutsch partner so heißt die
neue dating app die iranerinnen und
iraner zusammenführen soll
ganz im sinne der religionsbehörde bis
dass der tod sie scheidet in einem land
in dem kinder und co natürlich verboten
sind genauso wie sex vor der ehe und in
dem gerade viele junge leute beide
verbote regelmäßig umgehen
kommt die neue app dann auch vom staat
mit hintergedanken und wenig chancen auf
erfolg kamera seit jahren hat die
details es ist eines der größten tabus
im sittenstrengen gottesstaat baggern
flirten nummern tauschen nur in nischen
geht das abseits der sittenwächter doch
jetzt bietet der staat selbst seinen
bürgern eine app zur heiratsvermittlung
an hochoffiziell am damm partner soll
sie heißen plattform mit der neuen
plattform haben dann sind wir auf der
höhe der zeit denn heutzutage gibt es
bei der partnerwahl und der heirat viele
probleme kulturelle ökonomische und auch
zwischenmenschliche
als folge der wirtschaftskrise und der
hohen arbeitslosigkeit ist die
geburtenrate in iran in den letzten vier
jahren um 25 prozent gesunken
offensiv bewirbt das regime daher die
heirat als schlüssel zum glück das
eigentliche ziel der sittenwächter aber
sie wollen den außerehelichen sex
unterbinden
das gemerkt dass vor ähnliche
beziehungen zwischen mann und frau außer
kontrolle geraten sind und es will mit
aller kraft und unter dem vorwand einer
westlich geprägten app seine islamische
sexualmoral zementieren
so will man auch die kontrolle über die
jugend behalten und die als dating
portal getarnt will noch mehr
sie registriert die daten ihrer nutzer
und unterzieht sie einem psychotest und
so genannte service mitarbeiter sollen
den heirats prozess jahrelang überwachen
sicherheitsleute ich habe mich eingehend
mit dieser app beschäftigt und habe bei
den initiatoren leider keinerlei
experten gefunden die sich mit den
themen ehe oder jugend beschäftigen auch
keine soziologen oder psychologen und
was sagen die die es betrifft hier
scheint das kalkül des regimes teilweise
aufzugehen martin zieht die heirats
plattform als alternative zur 20
ich bin nicht einverstanden mit der
traditionellen art der heirat also wenn
die familie den partner aussuchen
ich bevorzuge daher diese app andere wie
orte sind da skeptischer
ich glaube dass eine solche er mit einem
land wie iran keinen platz hat er dir in
unserer kultur wird es immer menschen
geben die diese app für ihre zwecke
ausnutzen werde und so versucht das
regime weiter das privatleben seiner
bürger auszuspähen getarnt als
highlights aktuell waren der deutsche
wetterdienst vor schweren gewittern im
südwesten und süden teils mit starkregen
und hagel und auch im nordwesten und in
der mitte kann es heftig gewittern
morgen ist die unwettergefahr im osten
und süden am größten ansonsten scheint
anfangen häufig die sonne nur im norden
und süden sind schon am vormittag
schauer und gewitter unterwegs am
nachmittag kann es dann überall regnen
das ganze bei 22 bis 29 grad
schauen wir auf die tage danach bis
dienstag bleibt die gefahr von unwettern
durch gewitter und starken regen
bestehen am mittwoch wird es dann
ruhiger an den temperaturen ändert sich
nur wenig fehlen noch die lottozahlen
wie immer ohne gewähr
38 14 22 23 45 super zeitreihe die
angaben wie immer ohne gewähr weitere
zahlen auf lotto zdf de und im zdf text
auf seite 55 6 damit sagen wir zwei
danke für heute zumindest bis ihnen
genau und sind morgen natürlich am
sonntag wieder für sie da
bis dann